un
autre genre de sport pour les grands
couturiers de paris cette semaine la
course des présentations de la mode
automne-hiver 88 89 en commençant ce
soir par christian lacroix est un hymne
au mot pardon yauba grégoire francke bri
riche matière broderie soucieuse des
drapés comme les deux roues même est
belle comme des stars d'hollywood c'est
christian lacroix nouveau cru il
abandonne les volants but les jupons et
n'oublie pas avec ses drapés que les
romains sont pas séparables
la mariée rose en porcelaine et vraies
fleurs d'oranger j'ai un homme riche une
mode toujours très féminine taille
affinée par des corses les matières très
fluide
nous une légère comme un plumage pour
femmes oiseaux
à temps